Speaker 1: So almost immediately after Nikki
Haley's announcement that she's running for
president through the Republican nomination in
2024, the Trump campaign put out a confusing and
bizarre campaign email attacking Nikki Haley.
And what's really fascinating about this email,
which we'll look at in a moment, is it attacked
Nikki Haley for being too much of a leftist,
but also for being too extreme on the right. It
is as confusing and bizarre as everything we have
come to expect and see from the Trump campaign.
Take a look at this. So the first lines are first.
It's called the real Nikki Haley. First of all,
Trump's going to tell you who the real Nikki Haley
is. Okay. It starts by saying Hillary Clinton is
an inspiration to Nikki Haley. In a 2012 interview
with The New York Times, Nikki Haley said, The
reason I actually ran for office is because of
Hillary Clinton. So here it wants to tag Nikki
Haley. It wants to trash Nikki Haley by saying
she's really not a conservative because she
was inspired by Hillary Clinton. Of course,
it ignores the uncontroversial reality that
you could disagree with Hillary Clinton's
politics. But see Hillary Clinton's success as an
elected official and public servant, as someone
who is a woman as inspirational. That's not super
controversial, but she's not really on the right.
She's on the left because she was inspired
by Hillary. And then in the next sentence,
Trump slams Nikki Haley for supporting
Paul Ryan's plan for entitlement reform,
which threatened Medicare and Social Security,
saying, quote, Haley praised Ryan's Medicare
proposal at the time and said lawmakers should
examine Medicare and Social Security spending to
address federal debt. Then quoting Nikki Haley
herself from 2010, saying what they need to be
doing is looking at entitlements. Look at Social
Security, Look at Medicaid. Look at Medicare. Look
at these things. Let's go to the heart of what
is causing government to grow and tackle that.
They're playing that. Nikki Haley is too extreme
in what she wants to cut and in the government
spending she wants to reduce, which is normally
an attack that the left makes on the right. So
Haley's a leftist and Haley is too far right.
It's not coherent. But in the defense of Trump,
Haley's campaign isn't very coherent so far. And
Trump's attacks on her are also not coherent. But
Nikki Haley at some point might want to articulate
what policy is she actually running on. Now,
I say she might want to articulate it because as
I said earlier in the program, it's not clear that
she needs any policy in order to win a Republican
primary. Trump had some policy statements in 2016.
Most of them we all knew were never going to be
achieved. He wasn't going to replace Obamacare
and he wasn't going to build a wall that Mexico
was going to pay for, and he wasn't going to do
all the things he claimed. It didn't really
matter. It's not clear that these Republicans
care about policy enough to hold it against Nikki
Haley, but at a certain point, she'll have to come
up with something that at least she can put on
her website. And that hasn't happened yet. It's
all incoherent. And this is exactly what I would
expect much more of in this Republican primary.